You've probably seen those software as a
service product launch videos. They're
smooth, minimalistic, and you can make a
lot of money by making them. And today I
will show you exactly how to create one.
I came up with a fake software as a
service, and this is what we're going to
create today. If you've ever hired a
video editor, you know the pain.
Feedback scattered across emails,
WhatsApp, Slack, and Frame, without a
clear overview. Edit from solves this by
bringing everything into one place.
Projects, feedback, files, [music] and
communication. Now, to make it easy, I'm
going to divide this in three scenes.
And throughout the video, I will show
you the secret technique to transition
between these scenes. Now, let's start
off with the first scene. I'm here in
After Effects, and I have this uh
voiceover already, software as a service
tutorial. Let's import that. And you can
actually download this in the
description. If you want the full
voiceover, the deep dive, and also the
tutorial on this subject, then do join
the Full Stack Editor Club. Link of that
is also in the description. In this
video, I'm just going to go over a part
of this, otherwise this video will also
become way too long. So, do check out
the deep dive in the Full Stack Editor
Club. Check it out. Now, let's create a
new composition, and I'm going to create
a 4K 25 frames per second composition.
Duration, I'm already going to set quite
high cuz I know uh the voiceover is a
bit longer, so I'm going to set it to
around 1 minute. That's fine. We can
change it later, and just hit okay. Now,
I'm going to move in the audio, and
let's drag that in the composition. So,
the first sentence is, "If you ever
hired a video editor, you know the
pain." And I'm thinking of an emoji with
maybe a hire button that gets clicked by
a cursor. I'm first going to create a
background. So, I'm going to go to
layer, new, solid. The color doesn't
matter cuz what I'm going to do is I'm
going to add a four color gradient. Go
to your effects and presets panel, and
type in four color gradient.
Double-click on it while having the
black solid selected. And let's change
the colors. I want this to be a bit like
off-white. I'm going to color pick the
other color, and I'm going to do the
same here. And then this blue, I'm going
to make a bit less bluish, maybe
something like this. I'm going to turn
the blend up by a lot, and I'm going to
change the blue to be a bit more like
this. Maybe move it a bit. There we go.
As you can see, we have this really nice
soft gradient. I'm going to set the
jitter to 100% to make sure that I don't
have any banding. This will also add a
bit of noise to it, which I actually
like. Now, let's make a quick UI. I'm
going to go to the rounded rectangle
tool. I'm going to set the fill to fully
white, and I'm going to add a stroke to
it, too.
I'm going to make this really like light
grayish, maybe something like this.
Press okay. And now, let's make a UI,
which we can later on change, of course,
but for now, I'm just going to make it
something like this. Let's change the
roundness to be nice and high, not too
high, but something around 60. That
already looks really nice. I'm also
going to add a drop shadow to this
already. So, right-click, layer styles,
and then drop shadow. In the drop
shadow, I'm going to make it really
soft. So, I'm going to increase the size
by a lot. Maybe something like this. I'm
going to change the angle to be 90° and
I'm going to increase the distance, so
it's a bit below it. And then I'm going
to change the opacity, so it's really
nice and soft. It literally only has to
be like 5% and to make sure there's a
bit of separation in the background. I'm
also going to change the stroke color to
be a bit more light. I think it's a bit
too noticeable. Something like this is
nice. Great. Now, I'm going to import a
Memoji. This can be a custom one that
you created yourself if you have an
Apple iPhone. Or you can just find one
in Google, or you can even create one
using ChatGPT. Now, let's uh import
this. I'm going to put it around here.
Now, let's press S for scale. I'm going
to scale this person down a bit,
something like this. Then I'm going to
go to the uh ellipse tool. I'm going to
turn my stroke to none, and I'm going to
add a gradient fill to this. Linear
gradient is fine. Okay. And I'm just
going to drag it like this. Hold shift,
and this looks really ugly. I want to
change this gradient really quick. So,
click on the gradient color, and I'm
going to use the same colors that we
used in the background. Maybe a bit of
like a light bluish, something like
this. Okay. Press V for selection, and
let's make sure that this is nice and
smooth. There we go. Now, I want to drag
this below our image. Move this a bit.
If you hold command, it might snap in
place, which it does. It's nice. We can
do that. Control on Windows. Uh I'm
going to move this guy a bit, and what
I'm actually going to do is I'm going to
make sure that it's cropped off. So,
let's scale it up so the bottom hits the
bottom of this ellipse. Then I'm going
to use the ellipse as a track mat, and
I'm going to turn it back on. Now, I'm
going to parent it to the shape, and I'm
going to press S for scale, and I'm
going to scale it down a bit. So, I want
to make sure that it's nice and small.
Something like this looks really clean.
Now, let's add some text to this. I'm
going to just go to the text tool, and
I'm just going to type here uh video
editor. Let's make the color a bit
off-black, maybe something like this.
Let's move this text. Make it a bit
smaller. Now, I'm going to duplicate it,
command D, control D on Windows, and I'm
going to add some subtitle here. Maybe
specialized
in making VSLs and e-commerce VSLs,
explainers, and e-commerce ads.
Something like that. Now, this looks
really ugly, and that is because this is
a subtitle. So, we either need to make
this a bit smaller, maybe a bit more
thin. So, for example, I can make this
into uh light, and I can also regular,
and can change the color of the text to
be a bit more light, and then also make
it smaller. Something like this. Move
this a bit. Now, I'm going to change the
shape a bit because I want to have it a
bit more longer, so I can fit a button
under it. So, let's click on the shape
and unlink it. Make it bigger, maybe
something like this. And I'm also going
to make it a bit more thin. We have a
bit less space around it. Then select
all of our elements. Click on the first
one, then on the last one while holding
shift, and let's move this to maybe
something like this. And then I want a
nice higher button under it. And I do
that by going to the rounded rectangle
tool. This fill might even be nice that
we already have. Uh let's see. Let's
drag this. And I actually quite like it.
Uh so, let's go to the selection tool,
V, and let's drag this handle so it's a
nice soft gradient. What we can even do
is right-click on this, layer styles,
and then inner glow, and let's set this
to normal, and then the color
white, and then
increase the size by a lot, and then
decrease the opacity by a lot. And this
will just generate this soft glowy look,
which in my opinion looks really nice.
Now, I actually like the roundness. I
don't like how this is aligned, so let's
center this first so everything is nice
and centered. We might have to move this
circle shape, and I just want to make
sure that this is all aligned properly.
Then I'm going to select this text or
this title, duplicate it, and move that
here. Let's move this above the button,
and let's change this to higher. Now,
one thing is really important is now
black, and as you can see, that looks a
bit cheap. I want to change this to
white. So, let's change the fill to
fully white. As you can see, we have a
nice clean card. I'm really happy with
it. Now, let's get animating. What I
want to do is I want to have it zoom out
from this card. So, I'm just going to
create a new null object first. So,
layer, new, null object. Let's drag this
up. Let's select all of our layers
except the PNG because that one is
already linked to the shape. And let's
parent that to the null. Now, I'm going
to press S for scale, set a keyframe,
drag this out. Then I'm going to zoom it
in by a lot, just making sure that card
is fully filling the screen. There we
go. Then, of course, I'm going to easy
ease these keyframes. Keyframe
assistant, easy ease. Go into the graph
editor. Let's select the last keyframe.
Let's drag that out. Maybe even drag
that first keyframe to the left. Maybe
drag it out a bit so it's a bit more
quick. A really steep graph, as you can
see. Now, let's already enable motion
blur, and then enable motion blur on all
of our layers. That will already make it
look nice. Let's animate the elements. I
want to start with top left with the
guy. And what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to press S for scale, set a
keyframe, go a bit further to the
beginning, and set it to zero. Now, of
course, you can easy ease this. In this
case, I want it to bounce. And to make
it bounce, you can use an expression, or
you can use a plugin like Motion Tools,
but we can even do it manually. And to
do it manually, it's not that crazy. We
just hit F9 on our keyboard to make this
ease. So, we have this nice graph, and
let's drag this out. And then I'm going
to set this to a bit larger, so it comes
in. And as you can see, it already has a
bounce. However, it's not as smooth. So,
let's go into this. Can drag this out a
bit, the last keyframe. Let's drag that
out like that. So, it goes like this.
Maybe a bit too much. Can dial it down a
bit. And then what I want to do is I
want to move him into the screen, too.
So, let's press P for position, drag him
down, and let's easy ease this. So, we
already have this cool animation. Then,
of course, the text, we also want to
animate that. And to animate it, I'm
just going to go into the text. Going to
go to animate, and then hit position.
Then I'm going to go to add, and then
property, opacity. Let's move the
position to 50, and opacity to zero.
Open the range selector, and then go
into the advanced tab. Let's change the
based on to words because I want the
words to animate, not the characters.
Set the shape to ramp up, the ease low
to 100%, and then let's keyframe the
offset by clicking on the stopwatch next
to offset. Set it to minus 100%. Go a
bit further, and let's set this to 100%.
So, we have this nice smooth animation.
We can even drag this out a bit. And of
course, we can save this as a preset by
just dragging this to our preset folder.
Or we can of course copy this over and
paste it onto our text. So we now have
it pasted on the rest of the text, and
as you can see, it already looks really
cool. Now we can of course offset it
too, so for example, that this text
comes in a bit later, and then the
higher also comes in later. Now I
actually also want to animate the shape
anyway, so let's select the shape, go
into the shape rectangle, then into the
rectangle path. Let's animate the size
and also the roundness. And lastly, I'm
also going to press S for scale and set
a keyframe. Now press U to see all your
keyframes. And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to drag these out. So I'm
going to drag these out maybe like 1
second. I'm going to unlink the size,
I'm going to make it square, and I do so
by just copying over the second value
and pasting that in the first value, so
we have a nice square. Then I'm going to
make it really round, somewhere like
this, so we have a nice circle. And I'm
going to set a keyframe for the scale,
and then I'm going to go a bit further
down, and I'm going to set another
keyframe for the scale. This time I'm
going to set it to zero. So it zooms to
100% and then drags out like that. Now
this is really ugly because there's no
smoothness on it, and that's really
simple to do. We just need to select
everything, hit F9 on our keyboard,
let's go to the graph editor, and let's
make this nice and smooth. I'm first
going to select the scale keyframe, and
I want to easy ease this, so it goes
smooth like that. And then I want it to
easy ease just like this, a nice smooth
graph. Wee, just like that. And we can
even offset this a bit by changing the
scale, so basically it it scales and
already moves out. So maybe even move
this a bit more to the front. Now the
overall timing isn't great because it
all happens a bit too slow. Now one more
thing, I want to spice it up a bit. You
see this a lot in SaaS animations where
there's basically some shapes around
your shape. And to do so, I'm just going
to duplicate the shape once, press S for
scale to scale it up. We're going to
press T for transparency, and let's dial
this down to a really low number,
something like five. And then we can
just do this again, command D, press S
for scale, scale it up, command D, press
S for scale, scale it up. And I'm just
going to do this a few more times till
my the edge. There we go. Now it's
really not that visible, so select all
of them, press T for transparency, and
let's increase the opacity a bit, not
too much, maybe to 15% or something.
That is really dope. And of course, what
we can even do is select all of them,
press S for scale, set a keyframe, go to
the front, and then scale it down. Let's
select all of these keyframes, right
click, keyframe assistant, easy ease.
Can even go into the graph editor and
make them all nice and eased. However,
what I also want to do is make sure
they're offset a bit. So So we can just
select all of these keyframes and use a
offset tool like motion tools, or you
can manually do it by just selecting
them, moving them like maybe one
keyframe further, one keyframe further,
one keyframe further, and one keyframe
further. And let's select them all and
then move them a bit. So there's a bit
of movement in the background, as you
can see. It's a cool effect, and you can
do this with any shape. You can also do
it with a circle or a blob. Now I have
this cursor, which you can just find
online. I just drag it in, and we'll use
this to click on the higher button. So
I'm just going to press P for position,
set a keyframe. I'm also going to press
S for scale, and I'm going to scale it
down for now, and I want to have it end
here. So let's press U to see our
keyframes, and let's drag this out, and
I want to move it from maybe around
here. And to make it more natural, let's
go into the convert vertex tool, and you
do this by clicking and holding your
mouse down on the pen tool. So we can
make this into a nice organic path,
maybe a bit like this. Of course, we
also want to easy ease this again, and
go into your graph editor, make sure
that this is really nice and eased.
Let's drag these keyframes, and let's
see the timing a bit, maybe just like
that. So it comes in nice and smooth.
And then once it's here, I want it to
click. And to make it click, just press
S for scale and go set a keyframe, go a
bit further and scale it down, and of
course, copy this keyframe over and
paste it, so it clicks. There we go. And
if we want to be really fancy, we also
adjust the button. And a mistake that a
lot of editors and motion designers make
is they scale the button up once it gets
clicked, or they make it lighter. It
needs to be darker, and it needs to go
in. So what you can do is you can just
press S for scale, make sure the higher
text is linked to this shape because we
want to have that move with it. Let's
set a keyframe, and then basically once
it clicks, we also want to make the
button scale down a bit and make it go
back up. And to make it darker, we can
add a exposure, brightness and contrast.
It doesn't really matter what you use,
or we can also keyframe the colors. In
this case, I'm going to add an exposure
effect. So we can just go to the effects
and presets, and we can add an exposure.
And if you just double click on that, it
will add it to it, and then we can set a
keyframe for the exposure, press U on
our keyboard, make sure that this is at
the start of the click,
>> [music]
>> and then let's make it so it goes really
dark, and then it goes light again. So
now it should click and it be really
realistic, as you can see. Boop. And we
can of course also select all of these
keyframes. And if you hold Alt, you can
even drag these keyframes out a bit, so
it all goes a bit slower. Great. Now
let's go to the next scene. I'm super
excited. And for this next scene, we're
going to of course use a cool
transition. And what you see a lot is
match cut, where basically a motion that
happens in this first scene will
transfer to the next scene. And in this
case, I'm going to do that too. I'm
going to make sure that everything in
this scene moves to the left, and then
the next scene cuts really hard and
comes from the right. So let's start it
with the transition first. I'm going to
just use our null that we already have.
Press P for position and set a keyframe.
Now what I notice is that my cursor is
not linked to the null. Let's do that
first. So make sure that every layer
except your background, which I'm going
to unlink, is linked to this null. And
now I'm just going to go a bit further,
maybe something like half a second to a
second, and I'm going to move everything
to the left, something like this. Now of
course, you want to easy ease these
keyframes, so hit F9 on your keyboard,
go into the graph editor, and make a
nice graph that is nice and pointy,
maybe something like this. We can
quickly preview it just to see what that
looks like. That is nice. I wanted to
have a bit more movement, so let's
change it so it's more to the left. This
is nice. And now I also want to create
depth to it, so I'm going to add 3D
layers. In this case, I'm just going to
make sure that the cursor is 3D, and I'm
also going to make sure the null is 3D.
Let's press P for position on the
cursor, make sure we click on position,
and make sure your playhead is on one of
the keyframes. What we can do now is we
can move it more towards the camera. I
would say maybe something like minus
2,000. And what will happen now also in
the movement, you will see that there
will be a bit more depth. The cursor
will go quicker than the rest. That's
exactly what I want. Now as you can see,
the cursor did become a bit too big, and
also the location is not perfect
anymore, so let's move the location
first, and then press S for scale. What
I want to make sure is to select the
scale and scale it down, something like
this. That is very nice. So it goes like
this, it moves all the layers to the
left. Perfect. Now the trick is to cut
it all off right on the moment where it
goes the quickest. So if you look to our
graph editor when we clicked on our
null's position, basically I want to cut
everything off right at the peak. So if
you go out of the graph editor, I can
select all of my layers excluding the
background, so hold shift, hit Alt right
bracket, and then here we want to have
our next scene. Now for the next scene,
we have feedback scattered across
emails, WhatsApp, Slack, and Frame
without a clear overview. Basically,
what I want to do is I want to have all
of these feedback windows floating
around. And for this, I'm going to reuse
this shape that we already created. Just
saves a bit of time. So let's find our
original shape. Let's unlink this for
now, or unparent it. And then let's move
this to the right, and let's move this
on top of everything. Now I'm also going
to do the same with the text, command D
to duplicate this and unlink it. Let's
go to here. Make sure it's active and
drag this above. I'm not going to link
it yet to our null, we can do this
later. But for now, I have the text.
Let's make sure that this is animated at
the right time. That works. I just of
course need to change the positioning
and stuff like that. So for example,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
type here Gmail. I'm going to change
this text into a paragraph by going to
the text tool and then right clicking,
convert to paragraph text. I also have
some feedback here. This is fake
feedback that I generated using Chat
GPT, maybe something like this. Can now
move this over nicely, maybe move this
around here. Let's import some icons
that I downloaded. They're not all
perfect, but that's fine. Start out with
Gmail. So press S for scale, way too
big, and I'm going to make this nice and
small to make it nice and luxurious,
maybe somewhere like this. This works.
Nice first feedback message. I'm going
to of course make sure that this is
a bit more thin by clicking on the shape
and changing the size here. Now I also
want to move it a bit, so it's nicely
aligned. There we go. And to make this
even nicer, we can also add a bit of a
feathering to this by going to the
rectangle tool, selecting the text, and
then just dragging a rectangle something
like this, pressing F for feather, and
then feathering it by quite a lot, make
it look a bit more luxurious, and it
also makes it look like there's more
text at the bottom. Maybe a bit too much
feedback, but I think it also works
fine. Now, we don't even need much
animation because the text is already
animated. I do want to, however, make
the logo appear nicely. So, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to cut this
off. I'm going to press P for position,
set a keyframe, and then T for
transparency, set a keyframe, press U,
drag these out. And why I do this? Just
to make sure that it's matching the text
a bit. I can also, of course, like make
it bounce, scale up, things like that,
but it sometimes doesn't have to be that
crazy. We can just keep it minimalistic,
and that's also the nice thing about
these software-as-a-service product
videos is that a lot of them they're
nice and minimalistic anyway. So, having
it like this can just work really well.
Cool. And now that we made our first
one, we have three more to go. In terms
of placement, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to just make sure that all of
these layers are nicely cut off. So, I'm
going to select them, and I'm going to
cut them off, and I'm going to make them
3D. And now we have our animation, as
you can see. What I'm going to do now is
I'm going to link the text and the Gmail
logo. Let's move this down, so it's all
together. Let's select them all and link
it to the shape. And because they're all
3D now, we can just move this shape in
3D space. Let's move the Gmail logo
below the null object just to make sure
that these are all nice together. So, we
have the Gmail logo, text, and we have
the Gmail, and then we have the shape
layer. I want to basically link this all
to the shape layer. And because the
shape layer is 3D and the rest is also
3D, we can now move it more towards the
camera. And this is important later on.
Now, I can move this a bit to the left,
for example, move this maybe a bit up,
and we can even scale it down if it's
too big. So, pressing S for scale, we
can also scale that down. Cool. Now that
we made our first one, I'm going to go
to the next one. And this is really
simple. We can just select all of these
layers. It's command D or control D on
Windows, and then move this above it. We
can select the shape layer, move this
maybe towards the right, move this down
a bit, maybe press P for position, then
move it a bit more to the back. Then go
to the text tool, and we can change the
Gmail to Slack. Then we just need the
Slack icon, make the 3D, turn it on, and
it's way too big. Now, trick to get it
to the same spot, we can just go to the
Gmail logo, open this, and copy the
transform. So, I'm just going to copy
that. Going to go to the start, and
before we paste it, just make sure that
this is also linked to that shape layer,
and then paste it. And as you can see,
it will be on the exact same location.
Maybe it's not big enough. Let's see.
Actually, this is perfect. If it is not
big enough because you have a different
icon, that's totally fine. Then we have
to go into S for scale and scale it up a
bit. In this case, I can just delete the
Gmail logo, and there we go. We have
Slack. The only thing I now want to do
is replace this feedback. I have another
feedback line, so I can just copy over
this feedback. Let's paste that in
there. There we go. Now, I am also going
to change the shape so it's a bit more
thin, maybe something like this, just so
it fits the scene a bit. Let's move the
Slack also, so it's nicely tucked
together. Select all of these, and we're
going to move this down a bit, so it's
nicely centered in that shape. Look at
the padding. Two more to go. So, again,
I'm going to use the Slack one now. So,
let's select those, command D, drag it
up, bloop. Get the shape layer, press P
for position, let's move this a bit,
maybe down here, maybe a bit more
towards the camera. This one is going to
be WhatsApp. Let's get the WhatsApp
logo. There we go. And same thing that
we did before, we can just drag this
down, so it's nicely tucked together,
make it 3D, link it to the shape, and
then copy the transform. This is a bit
the same as the Slack logo, and let's
paste in some more fake feedback. There
we go. Nice. One more to go. Again,
command D. You know the drill. Now, as
you can see, it's quite boring, and
that's because we still need to add the
animation. And the cool thing is is that
we created that null, right? And we have
a transition on this already. So, what
we can do now is we can select all of
the shape layers. So, shape 1 2 3 4,
we've selected them all. We're going to
link them to the null while making sure
that we're a bit further in the
timeline. You just need to make sure
that you're behind this keyframe. And
then, once we go back to the front, you
will see
that they will all move with the motion.
So, if we play this transition, as you
can see, we have this really nice match
cut. Now, what is missing is continuous
motion. This is a mistake that a lot of
editors make. It just makes it really
boring. We're just looking at a static
frame, nothing is happening here. And to
do so, what I'm going to do is I'm going
to go to layer, new, null object. I'm
going to link the current null to this
other null, and we can also make the 3D.
It doesn't have to be, but we can now
press P for position, set a keyframe,
drag this to the center of this other
transition, go a bit further, and then
move it. And basically, what this will
do, it will make sure that even after
this transition has happened, we will
still have some movement in our image.
I'm even going to adjust our transition
a bit, so it's more dragged out like
this. The only thing we need to make
sure is that that peak is still at this
center point. So, let's go into the
graph editor, and let's make sure that
peak is indeed in the center. There we
go. Now, I'm not sure about the
placement. I'm going to make sure that
this Gmail is set a bit more to the
right, so it it doesn't fall out of the
screen yet. And maybe the Slack a bit
more to the top. Now, I'm also going to
offset everything a bit because now
everything comes in the screen at the
same time, and that always is a bit
boring. So, to do so, I'm just going to
select a few layers. For example, I'm
going to select the frame one, which is
this image and this text. Let's move
this a bit, so this comes in a bit
later. Same thing with WhatsApp, just
like that. Again, just so there's a bit
of visual variety in there. Now, let's
go to the last scene. And that is scene
three, and as you can see, edit from
Solves this by bringing everything into
one place, project feedback files, and
communication design specifically for
working with video editors. I want to
basically have maybe a circle or maybe
an element in the center with all of
these points, or projects, feedback
files, communication, have that linked
to it. But before we do, I want, of
course, another transition. Now, I'm
going to already set up the next
transition, and that is a scale
transition. I want to basically zoom
through this. And to do so, I'm going to
create another null. Let's go to layer,
new, null object, link this null two to
null three, make it 3D, and we're going
to press P for position, set a keyframe,
and let's go a bit further.
Also, make sure that all of these layers
are not cut off, alt right bracket.
There we go. And I'm going to zoom
through it. And the cool thing is
because these are 3D already, there will
be some motion. And because we created a
new null, we can even start this motion
a bit earlier. So, maybe move this
keyframe to around here. And of course,
like always, hit F9 on your keyboard,
make sure there is a nice graph to this.
Nice and smooth. And again, right at the
peak, I'm going to select all of the
layers that we don't want anymore, which
is our which are these. So, let's cut
them off. I don't want to see them
anymore. And actually, what I also want
to do is I want to change the
background. So, in this case, we have a
nice light background. I want to change
it to a bit of a darker scene. So, I
also want to cut this off. However,
there's a trick for this. Basically, I
want to go to the peak again. As you can
see, all of these layers are cut off.
I'm going to hit command shift D,
control shift D on Windows. So, this
will become a different layer. Now, we
can go into the effect controls and
change the colors to something dark,
maybe like this. And let's use the
eyedropper tool on the others. There we
go. So, we have this really nice,
elegant background. So, once it zooms
in, we have this next background. Now, I
actually generated this a fake logo that
I want to use now. I might want to
include this icon, too, but for now, I
just want to have a text animation. So,
let's just use the text tool. I'm going
to type here edit from Let's turn off
the image for now. Let's make this a bit
bigger, and let's select the from, and I
want to change this fill to black, press
okay, and then right-click on the text,
layer styles, gradient overlay, change
the blending mode to screen. So, now the
gradient will just be applied to the
black text, and let's click on edit
gradient, and I'm going to change this
to a nice light blue that we had to
maybe something like this. That already
looks really clean. I really like that.
Now, what I do want to, of course, make
sure that it's aligned in the center.
So, let's align that nicely. And for the
animation, I'm going to use a cool
technique. Hit animate, and then
position, and then again on animate,
enable per character 3D, so we can
change the 3D position of this. And this
will all make sense in a bit. We can go
now into the position and move that a
bit towards the back, maybe something
like 1,700. Then I'm going to add
property, opacity, set this to zero, and
then we're going to do the same thing
that we did before. We're going to go
into the range selector, I'm going to go
into advanced, and I'm going to change
the shape to ramp up, ease low, 100%,
and then I'm going to animate the
offset. So, let's set a keyframe for the
offset, minus 100 to
100%. Now, let's close the text, and
let's, of course, make sure that this is
nicely aligned. So, basically, once this
starts, we want to also have this start.
This looks nice. Now, I want to circle
around this, and let's go to the ellipse
tool. Let's change the fill to a radial
gradient, okay. Go into the radial
gradient, and I'm going to make it so it
goes from really dark, something like
this, to maybe a bit more light bluish
or really dark bluish. We can always
adjust this later on. Press okay. And
then lastly, I'm going to add a stroke
to this. So, click on the stroke, and
let's see if we can use the same bluish
color. Maybe it's a bit too bright, but
we can adjust that later on. And then
let's drag our ellipse. Hold shift to
make sure that it's a nice and round.
There we go. Press V for the gradient
and then I want to adjust that a bit to
be something like this. And as you can
see, we already have a nice cool
ellipse. Want to make sure that this is
below our text. And of course, I want to
also make sure that this is aligned in
the center. And we can even make this a
bit more transparent just so it blends a
bit better in the background. And now we
have four keywords, right? Project,
feedback, files, and communication. I'm
just going to keep it minimal. I'm just
going to add some circles to this. So
let's go to the ellipse tool and let's
turn the stroke off. So I'm going to
turn that to none. And for the fill, we
can also keep it a radial gradient, but
I want to change it to linear. It's just
a bit easier to work with. And let's
make some nice blue balls. I'm going to
make it so it's they're a bit more
light. Maybe something like this. And
the trick here is also to go to
brightness. B for brightness and then we
can increase the brightness and we can
go to S for saturation and decrease the
saturation a bit. There we go. Press
okay. Let's just make one just to see
what this will look like. Hold shift. I
don't want my blue balls to be too big.
Something like this. So let's go into
the selection tool. Change this gradient
and I want it nice and light cuz it
looks nice and fresh. Cool. Let's move
this. And if you hold to command, it
will snap into place, which is really
nice. That's what we want. Now once you
align this perfectly, I'm going to show
you a nice trick. Basically, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to duplicate
the shape layer
three more times. So 1 2 3. So we have
four balls and we're going to link the
first one to our ellipse that we made,
which is this background orb. We're
going to press R for rotation and I'm
going to set this to 90°. That's one.
And then link the next one. Set this to
180°. There we go. Link the next one.
Set it to 270 and link the next one.
There we go. So now they're perfectly
aligned, which is really nice. Now what
you can do, we can already link this
shape now to the null that we created
before. And I'm just going to link it to
the null one, which is the easiest. And
as you can see, it will now move with
it. I want to of course, like before,
cut this off. So select all of the
layers in the new scene. Hit alt left
bracket to cut it off. So now we have a
really cool match cut, as you can see.
However, what I don't like is the added
from the animation goes way too quick. I
want to change this so it goes a bit
slower. That will make it a bit more
elegant. I want to make the shape or the
ellipse smaller, something like this.
And then of course, we can make it
rotate on the Z axis. So let's also do
that. Maybe set this to something like
212 to 270. It eases nicely. Go to the
graph editor and let's drag this
something like this. I'm even going to
start this rotation already a bit
earlier. So it's already rotating. As
you can see, you have this really nice
match cut. And then once the animation
is stationary, as you can see, there's
no movement anymore. I'm going to add
one more transition. And since
everything is linked to this last null
anyway, we can just use this null for
that. I'm going to set a keyframe for
the position and a keyframe for the
scale. I'm going to go one frame further
and I'm going to press S for scale
again. Going to scale it up by a lot.
Let's move this. Now your text might be
acting weird. That's because we're using
that enable per character 3D. Now to fix
this, we can just go into the text,
press P for position, and just make sure
that it's moved more towards the camera.
So in this case, I'm just going to set
the P from position on the text to zero
and then I'm going to press S for scale.
I'm going to scale it down a bit.
Something like this.
Nice and small. Let's center this a bit.
So as you can see, we now have that null
movement and now it's perfect. What I
also want to do is press U on the
keyboard, select these first two
keyframes, right click, toggle hold
keyframe. And that is important if we're
going to add motion blur later on, which
I do also want to add to all of our
layers. And once it's here, I want it to
have continuous movement. So I'm going
to go a bit further and I'm going to
move it from left to right. Something
like this. Let's also make sure it's a
bit higher. Copy this over. Go a bit
later.
Paste this. Let's move it even further.
So there's just a a nice smooth motion.
We can even turn this in a normal
keyframe. So right click, keyframe
interpolation, and let's change this
back to linear. So it's a linear
keyframe. So we have a nice slow
movement. Same with this one. Keyframe
interpolation, linear. So if you were to
play this now, we'll have this really
smooth motion. Now I'm going to add the
text, but before I do, I also want to
make sure that the rotation of the shape
doesn't end that soon. I still want it
to animate a bit while we're here. So
let's drag this out. So really that last
animation happens here. There we go. And
then it's really simple. I'm just going
to add a text. We can even duplicate
this text that we already have here. So
duplicate that. Move that to the right
and we can change this to projects. Now
this is way too thick and way too big.
So let's select this. Make this a bit
smaller in terms of font size. Let's
move this. Make sure it's aligned nicely
somewhere around here. And then in terms
of animation, let's go into the text.
Open the text. And I can just use the
same animator. However, I do want to
change the position. Now it's using 3D
depth. I think that's a bit too much.
Let's set this to zero and let's make
sure it comes from the top. And let's
make sure the alignment is so it starts
here. So we have this nice text just
like that. It's like projects. I think
it looks really clean. It also aligns
with this motion of this rotation. I'm
just going to do this again for the
other three. And to do so, I'll show you
another trick. So what we can do now, we
can link this to the shape layer. And
that is of course the circle that we're
animating. If you now set a keyframe for
that Z rotation, we go a bit further and
and we set this to zero, it will go to
the next circle. As you can see, and we
set this to one rotation and then 0°, it
will animate to the next circle. And it
will look a bit lame because the
projects will move with it and I think
that looks a bit stupid, but we can work
with this. We just need to drag this
keyframe out. Go into the graph editor.
Make sure this is nice and smooth. So it
eases in and eases out. So let's just
drag this out. And then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to just fade out the
projects. So let's press T for
transparency. Set a keyframe and just
fade it out once it goes down. And once
we enable motion blur with this, it will
also look way nicer. So it just looks
like this.
And then we go to the next one. And to
get the next one, it's really simple. We
just go back here where we can still see
our text. We duplicate the projects. For
now, we're going to unlink it. So let's
set this to none. We can go a bit
further. Wee. Till it's right here. And
then I'm going to link it again. And I'm
also going to drag it out so it aligns
nicer with the animation. So now we have
our next text. I'm going to make sure it
starts a bit later. Might have to move
it a bit to the left. So we have the
first one, second one, and we can put
the text here. Feedback. Maybe we have
to align it a bit different and so forth
so forth. And let's do this with the
others, too. Now one more thing. I'm
going to select everything and enable
motion blur. And then you get something
like this. Again, if you want the full
deep dive, the project file, learn more
about minimalistic SaaS product videos,
and the whole ideation process, then do
join the Full Stack Editor Club. Link is
in the description. People in the club
have been getting amazing results. Do
also drop a comment what you want to see
next. Don't forget to subscribe and then
I'll see you in the next one. Bye-bye.